Israel's response to hamas's terrorist
attack has prompted criticism and
protest but is it breaking the rules of
War article 51 of the United Nations
Charter specifies that states have the
right of selfdefense they are allowed to
defend themselves from armed
attack what lawyers have agreed over
time since is that a state can use Force
as long as it is necessary to do so in
other words if you have to use Force to
address a threat or or or the reality of
an armed attack and as long as your
force is proportional to the threat that
you face so for instance if you had a uh
State attack you on a low level you
wouldn't be allowed to use nuclear
weapons to Simply flatten the state in
response that would be
disproportionate Israel has for many
years kept the Gaza Strip under a state
of blockade and in recent days Israeli
ministers P the strip under a Complete
Siege stopping all food electricity
water fuel and what loyers say to me is
that while a blockade can be legal that
there is a Prohibition in international
law on starving civilians and many of
them say that the tightening of the
Israeli blockade into a full Siege could
potentially violate that prohibition and
make this a potential War crime on
October 18th during a visit to Israel by
President Joe Biden Israel did say it
would allow food water and medicine to
enter Gaza from the southern Crossing in
Egypt International humanitarian law
that governs how armies Target things on
the battlefield is really clear it says
that armies can never under any
circumstances deliberately Target
civilians or civilian
objects but there are some lawyers who
are concerned that Israel's definition
of what counts as a military object has
stretched that idea to Breaking Point
for instance some say that Israel
considers uh that if a building was once
used by Hamas and even if hanas leaves
that the building might still count as a
military object that can be legitimately
targeted in an air strike there are some
observers who say that Israel's attacks
in Gaza whilst highly destructive aren't
necessarily more destructive than other
Urban Wars we've seen in the past
whether that's America in fuah or the
Iraqi Army in mosul attacking Islamic
State a few years ago so these legal
debates are really intense and I think
it's safe to say that they're really
contested